radio canada a une nouvelle présidente
catherine tate nommé le 4 avril dernier
vient tout juste d'entrer en fonction et
il est avec nous pour nous permettre
d'en savoir un peu plus sur sa vision du
diffuseur public et ses intentions
madame tête bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous bien sûr madame tête vous
arrivez vous avez une trentaine d'années
d'expérience en production privée vous
arrivez des états unis et vous avez dit
quand vous avez été nommé c'est mon job
de rêve c'est mon travail de rêve
comment vous percevez le diffuseur
public siby si radio-canada qu'est ce
que ça représente pour vous mais la
différence entre le privé et le public
en tant que diffuseur c'est surtout
l'impact qu'on peut avoir sur le public
canadien en général alors pour moi après
35 ans de travail sur les productions
comme entrepreneur en production la
raison pour laquelle c'était le poste
idéal pour moi on fait le poste de rêve
c'est que je peux travailler sur un
plateau beaucoup plus grand puis
j'espère est retourné au service public
parce que j'ai commencé ma carrière à
ottawa dont le ministère des
communications
est-ce que vous avez déjà déterminé
certaines des priorités qui vont vous
guider dans ses premiers mois dans ses
premières années de votre mandat ouais
en fait la priorité a premièrement où ma
priorité c'est de rencontrer les gens
les employés de radio-canada et de
cilicie bien sûr aimé aussi les
canadiens pour combien mieux comprendre
s'ils sont d'accord sur les services
qu'on leur offre
et puis ensuite on a quand même l'examen
de la loi de la radio sur la
radiodiffusion et ça c'est quand même
très important parce qu'on va revoir
revisiter le mandat du cbc et
radio-canada alors ça c'est sûr c'est
une priorité
c'est un rendez vous important qui vient
en 2019 assez salée
demande la liseuse maintenant sur ce que
fait et doit faire sivici radio-canada
pour vous qu'est ce qui est prioritaire
est ce que c'est
l'information a qui est nouveau ou est
ce que c'est le divertissement est ce
que c'est la production d'émissions
d'affaires publiques qu'est-ce que vous
avez là d'autres mandats non non notre
mandat est bien décrit dans la loi c'est
d'informer et d'éclairer et de divertir
pour le public canadien pour les
citoyens et citoyennes canadien alors
pour moi c'est s'il ya toujours une
balance ici on travaille avec eux dans
les trois
j'espère parce que c'est pas des silos
mais des trois voies
et si toujours important de trouver cet
équilibre entre les trois mais enfin ces
trois mandats qu'on a
vous arrivez ou alors que le secteur de
l'information est en plein
bouleversement
il ya une remise en question de la
presse un peu partout au pays à
l'extérieur aussi aux états unis donc
vous arrivez vous l'avez vécu comment
est ce qu'à votre avis radio canada
s'inscrit dans cette tourmente n'a en
fait parce que tout le monde est un peu
en questionnement avec les fêtes nous
peut-être les fausses nouvelles
le rôle du diffuseur public pour vous
dans cet univers là c'est une des
raisons pour laquelle je j'ai postulé
pour le poste parce que je pense que en
ce moment avec les en fait de la forte
perturbation de notre système médiatique
c'est c'est exactement le moment où le
diffuseur public joue un rôle plus
important que jamais si on nous de
garder de sauvegarder notre culture
canadienne et francophones aussi c'est à
nous de livrer l'information crédible
aux canadiens et aux canadiennes et bien
sûr de les divertir aussi leur livrer
une information crédible pour vous ce
qu'on doit prioriser l'information plus
régionales nationales internationales
c'est difficile parce que vous êtes
journaliste à l'étranger allant du fonds
des phases encore une fois si
l'équilibré
c'est sûr que la faux halal étrangers
très important mais il faut revenir à ce
que en fait le mandat du
du diffuseur public c'est de servir les
canadiens où ils sont au canada dont les
régions avec leur histoire avec
l'information qui le touche alors pour
moi encore c'est toujours il faut
équilibrer né le local est très
important mais le local pourrait se
faire de façon peut-être un cru mais aux
dépens de quoi à votre avis dans tout
cet écosystème qu'ils diffusent en plus
bien sûr on a beaucoup réussi sur le
plan numérique
et puis on peut livrer les allées les
impôts comme ça mais il ya toujours les
histoires qui vient de deux des régions
à il faut découvrir les créateurs dans
les régions et c'est là où la télé et
même les séries web peuvent jouer un
rôle important
vous arrivez je pense que vous êtes
fiers de ce que vous avez accompli comme
productrice et ce point de vue là votre
avis est toujours ce débat de genre du
secteur privé les producteurs qui disent
que radio canada devrait peut-être
devenir plutôt un diffuseur qu'un
générateur de contenu vous avec votre
sensibilité de productrice est ce que
vous êtes sensible à cet argument aussi
au contraire vous avez envie de vous
attaquer à la production de contenus à
l'intérieur
des murs de radio canada de quel côté
vous pencher mais j'ai vu j'ai assisté à
l'émission dé les dieux de la danse hier
et j'ai vu en fait une partenariat entre
un producteur indépendant et non tout
notre équipe et si à radio canada puis
on a travaillé ensemble et puis on monte
un spectacle quand même impressionnant
alors je pense il y aura toujours un
besoin d'avoir des gens à l'intérieur de
de cbc radio canada parce qu'on est
quand même goût on travaille comme comme
créateur ici mais en même temps je
trouve que les indépendants d'un aussi
au souffle d'air aux idées et puis il
faut travailler avec le maximum de
talent qu'on peut trouver vous avez
choisi de vous installer à ottawa oui
pourquoi avoir pris cette décision plus
tôt peut-être d'être à toronto à
montréal pourquoi ottawa ce que vous
cherchez à vous rapprocher peut-être du
pouvoir public quelle relation vous
entrevoyez avec ottawa il faut quand
même comprendre que j'aimais ma mère toi
alors je ne dis pas que je me rapproche
mais bien sûr blague à part le grand
défi pour le diffuseur public c'est de
ces de promouvoir notre marque et c'est
une marque très puissante
les canadiens aiment beaucoup
radio-canada et le site ici mais il ya
du travail à faire à un taux un pour
convaincre le gouvernement tous les
influenceurs sur l'importance de
de la radiodiffusion publique est ce que
vous connaissez bien le reste du monde
aussi est ce qu'il ya des modèles qui
vous inspirent ailleurs qu'au canada
oui bien sûr j'ai beaucoup en fait c'est
sûr que le pipi 6 et c'est un des
modèles les plus importants mais ils ont
ils sont très biens financiers ils ont
ils ont énormément de ressources alors
c'est sûr que c'est ce genre de deux
systèmes qu'on aimerait avoir aussi
madame tête je vous remercie beaucoup
venaient de passer nous voir
merci beaucoup merci